on this the eve of christmas i wanted to  bring to your attention the gift of one  lawyer  one lin wood one of the two main lawyers  in charge of all the election lawsuits  along with sydney powell  mr wood filed a verified complaint  that's a complaint  where you swear that the allegations  allege they're in are true and correct  it helps you overcome some of the  evidentiary hurdles that you might face  when you file a complaint  and of course when you attest to a  verified complaint like signing an  affidavit  you swear under penalty of perjury of  course in the most freudian of slips  ever mr woods signed under plenty  of perjury not under penalty of perjury  that is just the gift that keeps on  giving and if you'd like even more  holiday cheer check out the video i did  on all the laws broken in national  lampoon's christmas vacation  and i'll see you in court